playgrounds you got it put it around
that's what you got from the store get
just get your phones out ladies and
gentlemen
Oh
he's trying to do the Statue of Liberty
for time he has been in the dunk contest
that's a good shot because when you see
it in slow motion you'll see each each
thinness full spread out and we look
like he's warmed up no no I look me to
the full spread out but this dude has
been haven't been in in 11 years see
when he freezes out there that's a full
spread out 360 so maybe pull more
judging this though that is nice though
it's a little motion in real time cuz
first of all how many people get to let
its 60 and spread out that's I'd agree I
agree that's a good first dunk it's a
warm up dunk the crap that's the
toughest dump to be the first dunker of
the night
look at this eight only eight
come on calm and you can't dump donuts
and coffee killing you
competition anybody go into play mode
and play ball with this foot event
people D where he bought the fly okay
he bout to take off and fly go airplane
more right now and he's got a perfect
just birthday birthday
[Applause]
this movie is my birthday as well I
think through it all this yeah so if you
gonna stop and blow out the candle there
you go
take us yes we're gonna want the candles
your bloody birthday
hey come on D we you've seen a lot of
these dumps in during practice you know
exactly what he's getting ready to do
was his birthday if he jumps over the
birthday cake and then jumps over BAM I
know he's been the full serenade okay
well hey if he's gonna get all this he
better make his dump on the birthday
don't you hear me he better make the
dump on the first attempt you want us to
sing happy birthday
you better done with something special
way to get the crowd involved man I'm
sick of this guy happy birthday till he
ducks over such a good officer you happy
if it's not right I'm not sure if it's
right I'm singing happy birthday Kevin
hey kitty yes it's call ready for
takeoff ready for takeoff don't you fall
as you get down with it okay ready for
takeoff yeah you saw it you heard it I
want to see it I'm gonna be fair dome
yes yes it'd be wise tin already on your
scorch table
ready for thank you
are you thinking happy birthday song are
you singing happy birthday yeah not yet
no no he tried a windmill there
you tried to wear melon that's gonna be
tough I think you could do it for you I
think I would have tried this on my
second job yeah tell me a lot now is a
partial or impartial judge you count the
misty wait do you count to miss and yes
yes yes I take off for a minute
I personally penalize them for mrs. oh
yeah what do you bid 0.3 oh that's nice
though that it's nice going any that is
nice I'm sorry I'm gonna laugh amiss you
can't read a lot that be me that no
that's that that's that is not that
should be nice not all knives right
there that's to be all 9
I cook confident I got it see now those
are not not the B stores no white men
can't jump
I feel that I saw the movie I liked it
but I guess she never saw a Rex track
their trip very can call me a taxi one
we just heard he has a 44 inch vertical
leap at the draft kamba combine that is
the highest the third highest Marlin
Yelich Ellis's out here to be a baseball
that's right holding the basketball all
men because kept at was a baseball
player let's go
okay see I liked it in the day Kevin
when you take your point box because
that's an eighth day today it is not
really it's not really a nine it's not
really any you know but it's like an 8.5
- with Jason that is that's nice well
and he's got the National League MVP
from 2018 Yelich with the Brewers
luckily that's nine across the board
that's not across the board Kenny come
on come on come on
well here's the whatever like that look
at that that's really that was a nice
dunk I give on my a nine across the
board eight I'm with the way to one day
[Applause]
that nobody's seen before because this
last dunk contest is ready then he got
rocket you know Scottie till he's ready
he's been coming he's been coming see
the don't march on his shoulder right
he's big huffing from Orlando lift out
do you come out the back with this ready
come out the back
I'm not mad at that I'm not mad at that
and it ladies and gentlemen Eliza missed
a check that is a 10 here's the things
that's gonna look much better and I
listen to laughs with mrs. but I'm now
penalizing him for missing that person
come on man between the legs back there
man that's the chair that's the ten
that's its income on the ten that was
nice
be surprised if anyone gives him a nine
up there yeah overall ten seconds it
says we see before we didn't see some
we'd seen before the way we did that we
have not seen that we haven't seen out
obviously now that's why he gets that
first yeah we haven't seen out haven't
seen that I agree I agree the judges he
blocked any of their shots I wouldn't if
I was scottie pippen up d-wade I
wouldn't give on low score 34 year-old
sex ed I can't say this why don't you
say it why can't you
[Applause]
can I say it
if the man has a cape on and an [ __ ]
where does it go
[ __ ] a called uncle to call we can't say
Superman from the building
[Applause]
he should jump over you over you let go
bro ladies each other let go
Boise girl stepping out the pool putting
on the Cape putting on the Atlantis
chest two white howlite now it's cooking
and I will let you know Superman was
close but it wasn't the Superman in the
building right but it was still a nice
dump it's still at eight I do like it
right out Jimmy really you know old
school
I mean he's still talking fire at least
three more years
oh man that is that is still impressive
he could have taken off brother and
threw it in like he did before but he
wanted to make it with the Cape flying
the blue shirt the 24 today yesterday
hey I got I got peer pressured into the
score yeah
are we never another Chicago conspiracy
we have another disappearing
we have another girlfriend he wanted to
do something and out there happy with
this is Christmas you should have gave
Pat Connaughton on his first one no no
that was an 8 and this is an 8 knock it
off
I got it's the replay over here guys I
get to see it I think I don't know when
he's gonna do he's gonna jump and do it
he's gonna do about what just run up yo
mrs. backer it right there no and then
his season it'll run up his mouth then
his season was about seven foot no so we
we ought to take that consideration if
he jumps on if he hurts John is he's
getting cut tomorrow no longer on
Milwaukee park
I'm telling you don't count don't pat
you better get your adrenaline up don't
hold it against if d wade through
backwards is he trying to catch it and
go down blue back so my play I feel like
you need to move back some or or Yanis
you could take his younger brother who's
like three inches smaller there you go
he hit the back wall in slow motion he
hissed a minute boy it's gonna get is
gonna get he hit the backboard Jim
that's a ten that's a 10 that is a 10 he
hit the back I would have jumped over
that brother though
okay I say Pat I saw it baby
come on time you get held back you ain't
gonna explain dr. Pat listen you ain't
gotta explain it I feel like that's
attempting to team right they're
different
that's what we jumped over seven footer
wall six down in the half what do you
think okay are there still it's good
though that's daddy yeah you got a long
hair no that's a ten I will do that too
bad yeah yeah no they trying to win the
dunk contest and the NBA championship
he's got 95 it has a head of listen
that's why Holly that was crazy
[Music]
[Laughter]
back over here give her about a hard
time yeah look at Candace she's like did
he do it or now now he deserved that 50
right there man he deserved that well he
deserved a 9 on his first one to open up
some ice cream eat now what is this
young man I don't know he's got a fly
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
come on come on give them out
eh at work they can't do that in work on
down that you know dr. J impressed I'm
impressed
you look at the flight you look at the
elevation look at the finish yeah
and he still had room and he still had a
room he's no question he's that kind of
question right there he's coming to win
this he's coming to where he's in first
year he's comes in first place right now
and think about it now you get the guy
who won but you know what when you come
into this red you already have the floor
made up in your mind so it's not like
you're gonna shave
something the same it's nothing the same
great
okay mr. chance oh I can't wait just did
there he's taking the chance I get what
you just did there
[Applause]
I hope he's got asking him to love it
because I would not have chance the
rapper my future the dunk contest
champion so this is bit he's gonna do
basically the same done he's English but
when he used the mascot but uh but he's
jumping over Chicago right Chicago's
finest right
[Applause]
chance is so scared right now do you
think he's come on man they get scared
in everywhere
Oh God last year I have to do this and
my neck was hurting when the duck
contest is over
[Applause]
come on it's a good City anyone listen
to this man Eric Gordon has been the
most unique slam dunker in the history
of the contest yo he's in the history
look at these emotionally
come on give them out and give them to
give those fifties out go get that give
those fifties out like it's Halloween
trick or treat
trick or treat no yeah there better not
be a 9 over there don't want you giving
out fifties because it's a big rich town
[Applause]
he's come up with some creative da man
he coming for it there's gonna be a good
final oh man how many only to make it to
the finals right he's one of the Pat
Connaughton
haven't Gordon and Jerry all right I
gotta see this one Shaq's view here is 5
gee look at Shaq's eyebrows that says it
all I'm gonna see it nod to Mike enjoy
that's what I'm saying in Chicago right
come on it was one of those 88 dots
[Applause]
now follow - it was - it was - he ran
too fast he didn't get the crowd an
opportunity to see what he was about to
do he went into it he was focused he was
locked in but look at the power though I
would say look at this Ginny Ginny look
at that I say it's great done but
there's a similarity in the Ducks and
this is it now we got the press tell Kim
you're gonna work no Kenny then it's no
similarity between that I know he's a
Miami Heat no I'm not going to caucus
doing everything I need all eyes on me
and my dumb you're selfish man just put
them on a rim though right yeah yeah hey
put him on the basket how I'm doing it
hey orange jump over all of them
including the dancer underneath the
basket somewhere oh wait wait wait wait
[Applause]
I mean it's no it's so acronym you gotta
see the slogan you gotta see the slope
I do think that he was that the Jones
has been a better contortionist like
he's jumping just as high he's doing
well maybe not I think they're maybe not
but I think that this is 250 cuz yeah
he's this is it this might be 49 no
somebody might come on I this might be
us I was gonna give him a 9 somebody who
should be getting taken off the judge
panel this might be a 40 that look at
you come on man he jumped clear no I
think this might be for today that's why
I love the only thing 9.5 okay that
party going work these got work these
young guys okay this is the first time I
must see it ever and let me get my voice
ready get your tick-tock ready my
tick-tock is ready Evan
history say like that it's over
[Applause]
you can't win
[Applause]
[Applause]
that's what I'm talking about yes
Hawaii didn't Tiffany Haddish likes the
hey listen it is a Kevin that is that
was that it wasn't anybody dump to dump
so we top the top five in the history
the dump truck look at this look at it
is one hand easy side attack seven
deadly killer sudden dip them huh
no that should be over he second
I'm telling y'all air let alone another
hand hey every man hey listen man listen
[Music]
give it to him both man you gotta give
it up we gotta clean it gotta be let the
trophy give me so we can't be that cheap
do we got you trophies lying around here
somewhere you gotta come
I better not see an eye rash if they've
done it they can't get out he gave me to
be on the Night Man
weepy it all night I better not see
enough they can do 10 jumps in a row and
both okay here we have they got to give
it a ball double give it your boat hey
y'all
judges just need to stop there nothing
get off the dance
what they doing they don't fit knees the
same thing he didn't name dummies up
there you did say the same time I said
let's go home let's go let's go give it
to them both man give it to a bowl and a
judge's walk off walk up walk off
that's a 50 man you gotta company by
giving money by giving nice it's a time
look at their leaving keep going it yeah
get off there you go join it just walk
away walk away it's a tie man it's a tie
this it's over man y'all got something
dugouts up this Thank You Philly the
greatest we nicely game pick this he
gave the greatest thumb with a contest
since Jordan and diamond the n88 yep
this is the big one okay
sacoby Thank You pinky okay
it's over let it go now let it go let it
go fall who is seven five
you don't go with taco you win yeah you
win you win you tongue copa taco you win
come on man
come on man
you dunk over taco you when you don't
need to see it replay you need to just
put one sinner I want to tell you this I
feel for Derrick Jones jr. is over -
that was the 15 yeah but it wasn't
jumping over taco man come on get in
touch he never touched taco touch him
come on man that's seven going on in
woodshop clearly he cleared it
that's the hand he cleared him he
cleared taco man
taco taco yeah great I think he's gonna
do short you mean jump in the free-throw
line
yep are you gonna get he's going to the
logo the new logo
[Applause]
that's a one nail for one step inside
he's mad because he did it so hard but
it's still a fifty brothers it is I mean
still a fifty it's not a fifty because
he's one step in honey what step into
this madness expanded itself and look at
that one step in look at that that's
graceful to y'all that is graceful that
is beautiful
obviously beautiful well it's got to be
a 52 right that's not a 50 because of
the velocity the force the power
integers they have not done a dunk
that's not a 50
Candice Parker somewhere dominique is
that is now someone going to put a bike
in front of Dominique Wilkins out at
each other scores this is easy
all that
are you kidding
whole thing right man whoa this thing
run full all the same right
whoa this is 1988 highway rock trophy to
the winner of the 2020 AT&T slam dunk
from the Miami Heat
Derrick Jones jr.
[Applause]
[Applause]
once again Kristen Ledlow you're hugging
the trophy I would imagine that this one
here on this floor but where is this
trophy going to go I don't know
somewhere in my house but it might be in
the trophy case just by itself nothing
close to it this will go down as one of
the iconic slam dunk contests how would
you describe it it was great you know
great competition you know is I hate
putting on a show for the fans I just
know what we're supposed to do
congratulations once again give it up
for your 2020 AT&T slam dunk champion
Derrick Jones jr.
[Applause]
[Music]